the police they protect us they serve us
and they provide us with an endless
source of TV show one-liners rock paper
scissors gun well I know Serena Williams
but I know one thing it's all in the
wrist who'd want to cut your penis off
take a number
okay now you laugh but admit it you want
to watch the rest of that episode right
now hello
public trust in the police is one of the
most vital elements in a civilized
society but for many Americans that
trust has been undermined by a procedure
called civil forfeiture now I know it
sounds like a Gwyneth Paltrow euphemism
for divorce but but incredibly it's
actually even worse than that civil
asset forfeiture is really a mechanism
by which the state and federal
government can seize people's property
without having to convict them of a
crime most people can't afford to hire a
lawyer to challenge it it's really
legalized robbery by law enforcement I
think about it that is a tough crime to
report to the police give me a
description of what the guy looked like
well to be honest he looked a lot like
the guy currently asking me what the guy
looked like and if you think this sounds
bad just wait till you see how it looks
because the Washington Post recently
published a major investigation
featuring stories like that of this man
who was driving from Michigan to San
Francisco with $2,400 in cash that his
dad had lent him to start a new job when
he was pulled over in Nevada I gave him
my life since and registration and then
as he was looking at that information he
asked me how much money I was traveling
with Lee told about that money his dad
gave him which he kept in the trunk he
told me to turn on my air vents on high
and roll up my windows and get out of
the car because he was gonna run a
canine around it
dov didn't find drugs but he did find
the $2,400
he said no I'm gonna keep the money
because I've concluded through my
investigation here that you are
traveling from Michigan to California to
purchase drugs Wow there is so much
wrong there including the fact that any
policeman who genuinely believes you
need to travel from Michigan
to California to purchase drugs needs to
be introduced to the concept of the
University of wisconsin-madison okay
it's right there and the problem is
stories like that are surprisingly
common in fact since 9/11 under just one
program please have taken two and a half
billion dollars in the course of over
61,000 seizures of cash alone from
people who and this is the mind-blowing
part were not charged with a crime that
is the sort of police behavior that we
laugh at other countries for along with
their accents and silly hats the way
civil forfeiture generally works is that
if the police believe they have a
preponderance of the evidence that
suggests your property was or could be
used in a crime they may confiscate it
and it gets even weirder many folks are
unfamiliar with the idea of civil
forfeiture which is actually a case
brought against directly against a piece
of property where you don't need to be
proven guilty of a crime for your goods
to be taken away exactly you don't need
to be charged with a crime because it's
not you that's on trial it's your stuff
that's what these cases have
historically had I caching names such as
and all of these are real United States
versus 8850 dollars in US currency
United States versus an article
consisting of 50,000 cardboard boxes
more or less each containing one pair of
cracker bones and United States versus
approximately 64,000 695 pounds of shark
fins which must have been an amazing
court case and do you see those shark
fins in the room right now let the
record show the witness is pointed at
roughly 65,000 pounds of shark fins
guilty guilty and it's also worth noting
that your possessions generally have
fewer protections under the law than you
do under civil forfeiture laws your
property is guilty until you prove it
innocent
how can that be possible at this point
I'm surprised objects don't have their
own civil rights leader like Martin
scooter King or Harvey carton of milk
now now to be fair civil forfeiture laws
have had some positive consequences
they've crippled powerful drug
trafficking organizations forted
criminals and returned billions of
dollars to victims the problem is that
many police departments are allowed to
keep most or all of the money they
seized and knowing that starts to make
you wonder about the motivations of
these kinds of questions is there any
large amounts of cash in the vehicle ID
any large sums of money over $5,000 in
cash to these guys
any large Matthew a think you know I'll
take whatever cash you got in there and
is that a Slurpee in the cup holder what
flavor great never mind
do you know what I will take it I'll
take it the question do you have cash in
the vehicle is surprisingly common in
traffic stops and the police are
prepared to overcome any language
barrier to ask it tiene mucho mucho
dinero ensued rocky trailer let's let's
be clear he just said ten e mucho mucho
dinero in suit rocky trailer which which
sounds like an alien's first attempt to
communicate with humans after crash
landing in a Taco Bell in fact in fact
let's all just pause for a moment to
enjoy that sentence because every single
word of it is funny first 10 e
pronounced incorrectly mucho one of the
few words he knows in Spanish mucho
repeated words de niro a famed actor
in a rapid shift to English sooo rapid
shift back to Spanish trucky trailer
trucky trailer it's magnificent that is
magnificent it's a work of art now now
this happened in Tennessee a state where
local law enforcement authorities are
allowed to keep as much as 100 percent
of the proceeds from civil forfeitures a
local news investigation found multiple
troubling cases of people having money
seized such as George rebe who had
$20,000 seized after he was stopped for
speeding the police officer argued it
was drug money despite the fact that
Reba had a pretty good explanation I
told him I had active bids on eBay that
I was trying to buy a vehicle and they
they just didn't want to hear it
inspector Reba had proof on his computer
but the muttering officer drew up a
damning affidavit citing his own
training that common people do not carry
this much you whisk currency and did he
tell you that he was trying to buy a car
he did but you did not include that in
your report
if it's not in their attempt a little so
why would you leave that out
what do you mean you don't know
I expect a better answer from a police
officer than a four-year-old who just
spilled grape juice on the couch what
happened to your drink I don't know I
don't know if it's not in my glass it's
not in my glass I don't know I don't
know and look it's not always just a
roadside stop in 2008 police raided the
Contemporary Art Institute of Detroit
during its funk night because it didn't
have a liquor license
seizing 44 cars under the argument that
simply driving vehicles to the location
of an unlawful sale of alcohol were
sufficient to seize a car which means
you may as well seize any car driven by
any teenager on prom night because they
are all going to Chad's place Chad's got
the hook-up what we actually managed to
get the security video of that Detroit
raid and you can see the police burst in
and arrest people with the disco lights
still swirling in the single funkiest
shakedown in human history they each had
to pay $900 to get their cars out of the
impound with the exception of the one
person whose car was actually stolen
from the Lots to which it had been told
which seems what the sort of thing the
police should be investigating if they
weren't too busy raiding art gallery
funk nights and at this point you may be
thinking well sure the police
departments are getting a lot of money
from seizing stuff but I'm sure there
are limitations on how they can spend it
well allow me to take you to a 2012
Columbia Missouri Citizen Police Review
Board hearing how do you decide
forfeiture funds you know it's usually
based on the need well I take that back
fashion though I'd imagine you you sign
off on yeah it's there are some
limitations on it you know it's actually
there's not really on the forfeiture
staff actually there's basically no
limitations at all come to think of it
there's essentially gods with gods
we're like the anti Spider Man great
power no responsibilities I can't
believe this
to come up before and look his honesty
was not over it we just usually base it
on something that would be nice to have
that we can't get in the budget for it
for instance though you know we try not
to use it for things that we need to
depend on you know because we need to go
ahead and have those purchased but it's
kind of like pennies from heaven you
know it gets you a toy or something that
you need this is the way we typically
look at it that's right
that's right they buy toys with pennies
from heaven well they should know those
pennies may not be falling from heaven
so much of from the pockets of the
people they're holding upside down and
shaking and in terms of what kind of
toys police departments buy that really
depends for instance in Massachusetts
one DA's office used forfeiture money to
buy their own Zamboni
even though auditors noted we could not
determine where this machine was located
or the law enforcement purpose it serves
although that last one is obvious just
think about it because if you are
robbing a bank and the police pull up in
a Zamboni you're going to give yourself
up just out of sheer curiosity and in
Texas in Texas one DA's office had an
even more imaginative idea and I'll let
a concerned citizen of a public hearing
tell you all about it with or without a
law degree everyone here knows that
purchases of kegs of beer margarita
machines and bottles of Crown Royal for
office parties as was done in Montgomery
County don't qualify as expenses for
official purposes that's true in Texas
they bought a margarita machine they
were literally using this money as their
own personal slush fund
they will litter it's perfect the
analogy is perfect and look look if the
police need money for equipment we
should clearly be giving it to them and
if they need money for margarita
machines they should be paid for
that themselves but these civil
forfeiture laws have warped law
enforcement priorities and perception
and nowhere is that more clear than
Philadelphia Philadelphia officials over
a 10-year period have seized more than
1,000 houses about 3,300 vehicles and 44
million dollars in cash and civil
forfeitures holy
usually when someone describes something
taking 3,000 vehicles and a thousand
houses they're talking about a
hurricane now one of those houses
belongs to the sorav Ellis family and
the reason for that seizure seems a
little harsh from the outside police
arrested their 22 year old son Yanni on
drug charges $40 worth of heroin and
claimed he was selling drugs out of the
home police and prosecutors came armed
with a lawsuit against the house itself
exactly because remember the parents
aren't on trial the house is which is
clearly ridiculous the only drug
containing house that needs a lawsuit
against it is this one you're on the
edge you're on the edge house you're
this close you're this close to losing
your job you're good damn it you're good
house you're close house you're close
but you're good but you're so close but
you're so good house and once their
house was seized
the Soraa valises got to experience the
final problem with civil forfeiture
recourse can be incredibly difficult
here in dole Delphia if you have your
property taken you can come here to City
Hall and go to courtroom 478 and try to
get it back problem is the people that
are taking the belongings are also the
ones calling the shots inside the
courtroom the sort of Ellis's showed up
to courtroom four seven eight ready to
plead their case to a judge instead they
say they faced a prosecutor from the
DA's office
that's right their first step in
challenging the police season
I was in a courtroom without a judge
hearing their case how can you even
still call that a courtroom if you take
all the doctors out of a hospital and
replace them with otters that's no
longer a hospital it's better it's much
better but it's not a hospital I don't
know what I love it but it's not a
hospital in fact recourse is so
difficult that most people who've lost
after civil forfeiture just choose to
walk away rather than fight so this
point it should seem obvious that the
bads may be starting to outweigh the
good with civil forfeiture laws so we've
really got two choices we can we can
take a hard look at reforming them or at
the very least we need to reform our
network cop dramas to make them a lot
more representative of what is actually
happening coming soon
law in order civil asset forfeiture unit
get ready to go inside the thrilling
world of civil forfeiture knock knock
freeze police hands on the ground get
off the sofa keep them where we can see
him you're under arrest
what for you guys got nothing on me not
you sofa
coming this fall a procedural about law
enforcement shadiest procedure rough
night huh uh well it's about to get a
lot rougher that's 2500 in cash doing
and hanging out in somebody's glove box
huh answer me these cops are determined
and they won't stop until they get
everything every last thing you're dirty
right drug deal guns what is it I can't
help you don't talk to me I'm gonna beat
the out of you
detective Parvati civil forfeiture unit
brace yourself for heart pounding
takedowns is this big arrest send it
back up send in backup
the defendants are in animates but the
drama is anything but fresco
there's a pile of silver dollars next
door that says you do it you will lose
and I will win
stay on the streets too long the city
leaves a bad taste in your mouth hey I
know what I'll get it out
an order civil asset forfeiture unit
under crumple you up to look like a
cat's